hey jalen uh take us through doug
peterson telling you the news that you'd
be starting and what was your initial
reaction to it
um
obviously it's a great opportunity
um and
you know coach talked to me talked to
both of us and it's a great opportunity
moving forward so
we're focused on
things we have to do this week and
i just want to take advantage of the
opportunity
the guy who was once benched in a
national championship game by nick saban
for tuna tonga viloa and now enters the
fray for the philadelphia eagles under
under far less
glamorous circumstances because the
eagles are just trying to win a football
game chris look i you know i've been
thinking about this a lot from every
possible angle and and and there is
i think
a certain basic appeal to the idea that
if folks in philly are calling for
carson wentz's head
fine
let's see what jalen hurts can do right
with this mess that's around him and i
think we may quickly find out that it's
not like hertz is going to do any better
even with a week to prepare or two or
three games in a row where he plays it's
not going to be a dramatic improvement
if it is great right but i think we're
going to find out it's not going to be a
dramatic difference i i think that's
really probably part of the
the the you know part of the equation
here or the thought process i should say
for what philadelphia was doing i mean
one i think yeah they're looking at it
like we we need to do something the
offense is not good
they're hearing it everybody national
media philadelphia everybody it's jalen
hurts jalen hurts jalen hurts carson
wentz you know all that issues so i
think they know that and then the fact
that carson wentz yeah is you know like
i said earlier this week a beating down
puppy almost to where they go like
exactly what you said let's throw him
out there maybe he gives us a spark but
at the very least with the way we've
been and as crappy as we've been we're
probably going to be crappy and
everybody else will realize hey it's not
carson wentz and this quarterback didn't
make us any better either i would think
that was part of the the thought process
they're really in a no
lose situation as far as you know making
this move and seeing where it goes
uh for the most part i guess i guess
there is a little lose part of the
situation if it goes one way senator
jason kelsey chimed in on the situation
on wednesday perhaps his most
significant comment since the day that
he was dressed like someone guarding the
doors to the emerald city here's jason
kelsey on the quarterback situation
it's kind of hard to believe that we're
at this point now to be honest with you
um you know this season has not gone
the way any of us
obviously anticipated or would like it
to have gone but uh you know sitting
here three eight and one you know we you
gotta do something you gotta try and
make a change or or whatever and
you know obviously you know the offense
has been absolutely terrible
uh you know the last four weeks in
particular so
um
you know
i have no no doubt that this is not the
the uh
the final to the carson wentz story or
saga um i will always have confidence in
him as a person and him as a player at
the end of the day
this is ultimately a culmination of a
lot of failures on offense i don't know
the jalen hurts pick is a huge part of
that i think that that more comes that
this more comes down to
um you know a failure of
pretty much every position including the
coaches to facilitate a functioning
offense
and uh that's the biggest story here
wow
you rarely hear that kind of analysis
and candor from inside the house hey
doug peterson the phone call is coming
from inside the house i mean that that
is
accurate but it's also got kind of a raw
painful feel to it to hear it coming
from a guy who knows it does a guy who
knows a guy who's got you know all the
you know stripes and
badges and honors and everything in the
locker room to be like hey he's a stud
he's the me he's one of the best centers
we've had in football in the last 10
years so and there's no there's no you
could tell with the way he's talking
there and then like there's no nonsense
he's not playing games with anybody he's
just shooting it straight he's been
around he's been on a super bowl team he
realizes like he said it's just it's bad
at every level every level and he's seen
carson wentz carry the team last year
and he was there with carson wins in
2017 so he's not going to give up on a
guy where he's seen how good he can be
when it's all rolling and you know i
appreciated that that that whole snippet
there that was really well said and well
done by him
he's one of the few that can do it too
because he's contemplated retirement and
decided to keep going and he clearly
falls into the danny glover lethal
weapon i'm getting too old
yes you know what so what are they gonna
do what are they gonna do cut him right
because he was honest about what's going
on from a fan perspective from a media
perspective it's refreshing
to hear someone basically confirm what
we've all been thinking and seeing even
though it's not all that difficult to
see it a lot of times the people on the
inside are in denial and maybe maybe the
best way to turn it around chris is to
recognize it i i don't know that you can
do anything about it reminds me the
bears situation when matt nagy talked
several weeks ago after they lost to the
rams with the defense of chicago scoring
more points than the offense in that
game it's not like you can just wait a
magic wand and make it better you're
limited by the guys you have yes
there's really there's not going to be
some magical transformation you know
maybe we see a few plays in the game
where they catch the saints off guard
this week because
it's a new jalen hurts running play or
something like that but i got a hard
time even believing that's going to
catch the saints off guard because
they get to see guys like taysom hill in
practice all the time and probably have
a pretty good understanding of how a
quarterback run type offense will work
let alone you know what people got to
realize too is
this offense is not great and doesn't
lend itself to a lot of open receivers
to begin with you know um and
now you have a quarterback who you're
always reigning in a little bit and you
got to reign it in because yeah he
hasn't played this year and he is a
rookie he's not going to be able to do
some of the things carson wentz does at
the line of scrimmage and all of that so
you know that's another factor in this
too so i'm interested to just see how
the offense looks and where it goes from
here but like i said i don't think there
was any bad side i guess the only
negative maybe for philadelphia is what
jalen hurts does really good and now be
going to the offseason and go wait you
know the eagles look pretty good with
jalen hurst and now you have a real
issue and that's where maybe that's
maybe the worst thing that could happen
to the eagles in this situation
they already have a real issue and the
question is how many changes can be made
will be made after this season and how
much of it will be 2021 hot seat time
for everyone involved but it just it has
felt in recent weeks like it's moving
towards some sort of finality especially
because and what team do we talk
where was i i was talking about this on
chicago radio yesterday about the bears
we're at the point where and i think
this applies in both cities that the
silence of ownership becomes deafening
remember last year about this time
lion's ownership came out and said
matt patricia and bob quinn are safe
right if you don't get that message soon
from jeffrey lurie in philly or someone
named mccaskey whether it's george or
someone else or ted phillips in chicago
you really start to wonder what's going
to happen when the season ends that
we're getting to the point where you
need to hear that people are safe or you
you start thinking maybe people aren't
safe yeah yeah i mean you're right
you're right i mean chicago is one i'm
gonna have my ear too because that that
i think is like a real possibility as
much as things might be unraveling in
philadelphia i just don't think you
could be thinking about firing this
regime yet i don't you know i i think
this is one thing where what they've
done you jeffrey larry needs to say it
right needs to go out and say it i agree
no doubt about it yep
i'm mike tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights from nbc
sports